this is a dragon bear with me so the
ancient dragons are defined by their
gravel Stone scales which grant them
their immortality these Stone scales
weren't passed down to their mortal
descendants though gravel Stone can be
found in the hearts of these lesser
creatures and so it is that after
slaying a mortal Dragon you loot its
Immortal heart still beating even now if
the dragon slayer wishes to become a
dragon then they can partake in Dragon
communion consume enough hearts and the
transformation will begin with the
development of slitted draconic eyes and
these same eyes can actually be found on
the Rune Bears what's more back in Elden
Ring's Network test zulie the witch
discovered that a dragon heart could be
looted from a rune bear who existed out
of bounds not to mention Rune Bears even
have stone sticking out of their chests
so in conclusion perhaps the Run bears
were becoming dragons too to learn more
about the dragons check out my full L
video on YouTube